pour michel au luxe les jouisseuse
interdits aux moins de 18 ans et pour
votre ville et pour brimant là une ville
de 3000 habitants
nous avons toutes les semaines un film
porno brinon une petite commune rurale
enclavée entre fief du dr est un bastion
communiste une population à l'image de
la majorité silencieuse
seul le bulletin paroissial fulmine
contre le porno mais face aux fidèles le
dimanche
le curé ose-t-il mettre les pieds dans
le plat
deux allusions très discrète est
difficile parce que on risque alors de
faire une publicité supplémentaire pour
prendre la température une petite
enquête dans la rue il en ressort que
personne au grand jamais n'a vu de film
porno en revanche s indigne et souvent
contre le voisin
depuis nous avons des films pornos dans
notre vie c'est vrai le film porno à
éloigner les familles des salles de
spectacles sera phénomène connu des
sociologues et il est encore plus
sensible en province les séances elles
sont peu nombreuses samedi et dimanche
une ou deux semaines généralement le
soir sur trois films projetés deux porno
il ya toujours du monde
et comme
90 % les salles pourquoi c'est le seul
film que le client de province se
déplacent pour voir wagon donc à une
clientèle exactement est plus grande en
province que pour les autres films bien
sûr une salle de 100 personnes ya 95 80
% de personnes qui ont plus de plus de
40 ans 35 40 ans il me le 50 et 60
on retrouve cette hypocrisie de
certaines personnes qui vont voir des
films pour nous un autre on kilomètres
de chez eux pour ne pas se faire lors
auprès de leurs petits copains
qu'est ce qui se passe ici en oui le
compare tôt d'ailleurs ce qui signifie
que les gens des villages voisins
viennent ici certainement
et c'est les gens d'ici vont d'ailleurs
il en faudrait une des candidates
hongrie qui joue qui est ça qui joue
pour les gens plus âgés les jeunes
111-100 fiscaux france
à la campagne comme à la ville
l'invasion du porno est aujourd'hui une
réalité reconnue tolérée mais peut-être
pas totalement admise ainsi récemment à
brienon le conseil municipal a délibéré
sur l'éventualité de boycotter
l'affichage il n'en est rien sorti est
contre le film lui même
on ne peut rien faire cette impuissance
place le problème à un autre niveau
au fond même alerter l'opinion et puis
peut-être lancer une campagne à
l'échelon national mall je crois que
c'est le plus efficace est simple le
site même salle c'est devenu une affaire
de au fond une affaire de gouvernement
beaucoup plus que comprend le cas qu'il
me qu'on fasse au plan local puis
l'église est ce qu'on peut faire nous
mettre en garde les gens majorité des
gens sont contre ce pour nos qui va
contre l'éducation des enfants les
enfants recherche certainement une
éducation sexuelle mais serait peut-être
préférable de la recevoir dans les
familles plutôt que aller chercher cette
ré éducation sexuelle bidon dans les
salles pour le rural en contact avec la
nature c'est une évidence la sexualité
fait partie de l'ordre des choses
projeté sur un écran et l pernicieuse
pour les jeunes les adultes une question
d'éducation
mais les tabous reste tenace pudeur
hypocrisie à brienon personne n'a osé
dire j'ai vu du porno mais ce soir là la
sortie du cinéma était un aveu
[Musique]